non mais qu'est ce qu'un écrivain dans
la société du spectacle parlant
tranquillement en plein milieu du palace
avec philippe sollers philippe sollers
tu publies chez gallimard un roman qui
s'appelle le lys d'or est à l'autre bout
cas chez plon qui s'appelle carnet de
nuit on va commencer par le lys d'or
alors c'est l'histoire d'un type
s'appelle rouvray cac 40 ans simon
rouvray cac 40 ans qui se trouve un jour
chez un chez un antiquaire qui rencontre
une femme qui s'appelle rennes de
l'homme c'est beau comme non mais
personne n'ya vu malice parce que ça
s'écrit elle a eu m peut-être elle a eu
lieu non mais tu sais les gens
les gens ne se rendent pas très bien
compte des choses secrètes se passe dans
l'église c'est un livre très secret avec
un message sous jacent qui peut se lire
comme un roman quasiment comme un roman
policier voilà un type qui s'appelle
simon rouvray au passage alors sus si je
veux attirer l'attention mais tu t'en
fous enfin on peut dire comme par
exemple on peut dire que le duc de
saint-simon s'appelait louis ii ouvre
mais c'est pas grave
alors on laisse tomber ça il s'appelle
simon rouvray il a 40 ans il est
professeur dans un centre d'études
religieuses ses traductions charnois par
des chinois s'intéressent au taoïsme
c'est à dire les techniques très précis
y compris comparer ils rendent compte
cette femme s'est dit une nouvelle
strate riche pas de 8 ans qui
bizarrement va refuser d'avoir avec lui
une relation physique mais en revanche
pas lui demander d'écrire la relation
qu'ils ont enfin sa vie de leur relation
voilà on y est donc elle va le payer
pour ça une situation tout à fait
nouvelle tendrement de tous les siècles
parce que c'est la première fois qu'on
voit une femme payer un type pour
raconter quelque chose alors lui il va
essayer de son côté en racontant leurs
relations en même temps que l'histoire
de sa vie parce qu'il intéresse elle
oui il va essayer de la séduit parce
qu'ils lui envoient tout et 20 pages qui
raconte et donc le roman c'est ça c'est
tout les 20 pages ses réactions et la
façon qu'il a de la séduire en lui
proposant par exemple certaines choses
un peu un peu un peu étrange
si c'etait un
certaines choses sexuelles et ryan a
quitté allumé quand même pas mal c'est
jacques pierre amette dans dans le point
jacques-pierre amette qui s'appelait
alors ils disent on lui voue mais tous
les trois dans le même sac 1 il ya un
bhl jean-edern hallier et toi est-ce que
déjà à mettre dans le même sac que les
deux autres qu'est ce que ça te fait
marquant c'est la race camp des cantons
des raflés par la presse moi je alors il
va pas tu te le dirai pas de mal des
gens qui sont donc me dira ce que l'on
voudra près tous les trois dans les
oripeaux la romantique et importe quoi
et n'importe quand cela arrange
il faut trois salariés sur l'arctique
est truffé d'erreurs il dit n'importe
quoi la critique aujourd'hui il est
derrière n'existe pratiquement plus les
types n'ont pas le temps de lire des
livres
il parle à propos des images qui croit
avoir déchiffré tom bon c'est tout je
vais mais très bien me dis que tu fais
office chez gallimard de karl lagerfeld
et pour les profs devant les
transpalettes qui fait office de barre
oui oui massue malone en son nom mais
c'est bien je sais pas ce que tu penses
de la guerre faible et dante moi j'aime
beaucoup où l on met ça va ce plutôt des
bonnes comparaisons mais oui mais pour
lui si des reproches et alors il dit que
son livre ne reflète en rien la société
française pas reprendre l'info ça c'est
vrai
c'est absurde parce que qu'est-ce que la
société la société qui croit existantes
et pas celle à ce gala sienne il ya la
même vie à la mienne puis à celle de
n'importe qui donc le regard subjectif
complètement sur la société
il suffit d'avoir un regard éveillé pour
pour inventer une société tout entière
donc il sans citer un reproche alors non
mais tous les trois c'est vrai également
réaliste socialiste
c'est vrai qu'avec jean edern et bernard
henri lévy vous avez tous les trois
comme up aucun rapport c'est lui qui
nous rappelant sans nom sinon il ya
aucun rapport relis font grand bruit
quand même oui malheureuse cause il dit
que finalement vous êtes plus habiles à
monopoliser les médias qu'à écrire des
livres sur le jaloux il ressent leur
ça veut dire ça c'est la connerie il y
avait aucun rapport mais pour être plus
concret est ce que tu crois pas que pour
un auteur a le choix entre la retraite
et le tourbillon quand même moi je crois
qu'entre la retraite et le tourbillon il
ya une autre voie qui est celle de
l'obstination que tu n'est en mesure ni
l'art ni le tourbillon c'est à dire on
se sert du tourbillon et on est en même
temps dans la retraite que chateaubriand
dessins de l'hermine de nantes us et
c'est mettre sa main dans le siècle et
son intelligence au désert ça veut dire
c'est une bonne attitude schizophrénique
c'est à dire on hats à madame siècle on
à son intelligence au désert et on est
là comme ça entre les deux on dit que
j'ai trop nombriliste pour faire de la
fiction entière c'est vrai que dans ton
bouquin on sent que tu raconte une
histoire qui en même temps tu parles tu
finis toujours par et à l'état culture
parler de toi non non non oui par le
droit non dont je parle de tas de choses
qui sont pas forcément moins en plus le
narrateur se livrent à des idées assez
différentes de dire que la littérature
dans la société de spectacle où on vit
serait finalement devenue la ligue
l'exhibitionnisme de l'auteur dans tous
ses états non la littérature dans la
société du spectacle dans la tête tout
seul n'a plus de raison d'être et on ne
veut plus des cris par conséquent le
premier il montre sa détermination des
pays bas doit être marginalisés je
résiste je ne suis pas marginaliser donc
je trouverais l'air donc je devrais
l'être quand même
donc c'est une lutte comme ça entre
entre une pression qui voudraient se
débarrasser des écrivains moi j'ai une
confiance totale dans les crimes je
passe dans l'écrit comme du mozart tu
sais dans la plus dangereuse nous
passons avec la musique par la force de
la musique nous passons par la sombre
nuit de la mort évidemment avec l'écrit
j'allais passer à travers la saint-jean
beaucoup mieux travel à son produit de
labeur mais des amis oui ce
fonctionnaire un vent des 12 milles et
sollers devant 120 mille ans
ça me préoccupe pas à bord ou non tu
connais le portrait chinois
alors personne comme ses lunettes noires
va pas de faire un portrait chinois
standard parce que le portrait chinois
en demande toujours aux gens si vous
êtes une orchidée sur youtube nous ici
on fait lentilles portrait chinois au
plus près
je te dis si tu étais un défaut du srec
elle défaut la différence si tu étais
une injure
allez vous faire [ __ ] si tu étais une
maladie
pire que le sida est ce possible
d'ailleurs au fait c'est parce que c'est
à cause du sida tu crois qu'elle se
refuse à lui
rennes de l'homme sait bien qu'il ya une
sorte de peur je dire ah ouais à qui
redistribue toutes les cartes et que ça
va être très intéressant pour les vrais
professionnels de jouer de cette peur
ambiante
si tu es tellement des vampires nouveau
sans valeur s'il était à microbes aux
celui de la vie un insecte 1,5 le
scarabée immortel un reptile
là le serpent de la genèse c'était un
vis à vis mais la notion même de vie si
tu étais un supplice un supplice
toujours la chose privée
keynes qu'il se serait donc à laquelle
perso un supplice auquel personne
n'aurait taxe est un supplice intime
oui tout à fait un supplice moral moral
si tu étais un supplice tu seras un
supplice morale un supplice morale qui
va trésor formation et un accident
l'accident
[Musique]
la vie est un accident constant les
corrections de ne rien rater de linars
dit tu es abonné vous mettez un pouce
bleus